we're now joined by somebody who well
will be interesting to hear what the
view is of the parties that former
general secretary at Lord McNichol on
his assessments of where things went
wrong for labor
I mean we've we've heard the take of
which at Bergen who says it was a brexit
election we've heard the take of
Caroline Flint who says that actually it
was not connecting with some of those
traditional heartlands whether that was
on brexit or jeremy corbyn what's your
assessment of what happened so both of
them are right and bricks it was a huge
issue
I'm with in the election but as Caroline
said it wasn't the only issue I am on
the doorstep door after door I'm Jeremy
came up both I am as an individual and
trust in and Jeremy to be Prime Minister
but also within the the manifest during
the delivery of that and then there was
that there was another ratio by where we
were I'm targeting I'm you know in
Richard taught by Richard Berg and
talked about 2017 in 2017 we did put
resources and to make sure that we held
on to our labor seats that wasn't done
this time and we didn't do that and even
into it was a bit too ambitious you
saying that they went on the attack too
much in the Tory help marginals rather
than shoring up support in some of those
that you won last time
so you always showed up the support and
the seats that you need to hold and you
know we saw though you know we're down I
am 59 seats but I'm to 203 you know the
worst result since 1935 for you know
worse than micro fitting in 1983
so you need to do both you need to show
up where you need to I am returning your
MPs and then you need to go on the
offensive as well so even in 2017 we
still lost six members of parliament in
2017 if we held on to them we would have
been in a better position I'm but too
much of the support too much of the
resources was going into places
chamfered Oxbridge seats that we were
never ever going to win and if we had
put those resources into Kensington or
actually move some of those resources up
to the north of England we may well have
had a far better result and ended up in
a better position and why were those
mistakes made was it because
we'll learn the wrong lessons from 2017
or do you think it was the ground war
wasn't quite good enough or people were
just in denial as some of the issues on
the doorstep I think it was actually I'm
all of those but the the the biggest
session and the one that kept on coming
through time and time again I'm was was
Jeremy I'm was his ability to be Prime
Minister and trust I trust in him I'm it
just wasn't there when you were speaking
to two people I'm on the doors
I'm and yes of course brexit was I am a
big part of that but actually I'm being
able to been able to reach out to the
communities that you know we have
represented for decades and offer them
something that they can see is the best
way forward and it's right for them and
something that they actually trust and
believe in and believes that we can
deliver on I'm it's just so important
and we just didn't do that
is it right to lay so much blame at the
foot of Jeremy Corbyn though I mean
Labor's left lost for Jung relations in
a row now I'm here wasn't leader for all
of them he actually was he was also
leader in 2017 when he performed much
better than expected is it really his
fault well yes I am because I'm Jeremy
Corbyn and Corbin ISM control the whole
of the Labour Party just now you the
National Executive I am at the Shadow
Cabinet that policy agenda this election
around
Corbin ISM and Jeremy Corbyn so yes
absolutely does
I'm live there I am we do need some time
of reflection but actually there's some
really important decisions coming up in
Parliament I'm over the coming weeks and
over the coming months and immediately
we need to be holding Boris Johnson
Michael Gove as you heard earlier their
feet to the fire in terms of their
policies and you know Richard Perkins
right on I'm live delivery will Boris
Johnson deliver on the NHS will he
deliver on education you you look at the
inequality that is out there just now
you look at the homelessness is on one
Street it's as if the conservative have
not been in government for the last nine
years they've been there for the last
nine years they've been in power for the
last nine years I
but what we need now is to hold them to
account
I'm follow the decisions that they are
going to make do you think that means
that Jeremy Corbyn should stand down now
yeah I think you know Jeremy should
stand down no we should move to a
caretaker I'm leader like he said I mean
John McDonald says he doesn't want to do
it he would yeah well go to one of the
the grantees from before so the Harriet
Harman or Hilary Baron or Yvette Cooper
bring in someone I'm who can actually
put the pressure I'm on I'm Boris
Johnson on the Conservatives while we go
through upon me while we go through the
next leadership election at the same
time there is that not just turning the
clock back I mean the the people that
you mentioned in many ways are from an
area which also fails to win against the
Conservative Party yeah no it did I'm
but what we all we need to do is get
into I'm a leadership election so that
we can actually work I I am as Caroline
said what are the answers I'm to the
problems that we face just now what are
the solutions I'm unlabelled win when
there are a broad coalition reaching out
across the whole of the country not just
the northern heart ones not just live
metropolitan I'm cities I'm across the
United Kingdom but reach out across the
whole of the United Kingdom and then to
Scotland
I'm as well and Richard Bergen in the
interview said that one of the things
that came up on the doorstep about
Jeremy Corbyn was anti-semitism now
there have been accusations that some of
the issues come from your time when you
were general secretary John McDonald
said last year the party for example was
bringing forward mechanisms that should
have been implemented ages ago
ie when you were in charge yeah do you
take responsibility for it so yes I am
and I apologize for some of those
decisions that were that were made we
have the eh RC investigation that's I'm
going on just now but Jeremy Corbyn was
the leader of the Labour Party and
Jeremy Corbyn could have and should have
acted
it's fine to say you know we are going
to have zero tolerance to anti-semitism
that is correct but what then Falls from
that is leading I'm actually leading by
example we tried to bring forward extra
member
I'm all staff to investigate
anti-semitism that was arising across
the the Labour Party membership that was
blocked many of the other proposals that
I'm came through in the earlier reports
we're implemented I'm this is this is
something that started and rose under
Jeremy Corbyn and it could have been and
should have been I am eradicated as
people should have been suspended
immediately they should have been
investigated and they should have been
dealt was were still dealing with it
he's on the last summer close to Jeremy
Corbyn claim that some of those Booker
just came from you as well absolutely no
the the there were systems and processes
that were in place
I mean they were worked through the
staff and the team who were
investigating and taking these through
to the national constitutional committee
through the Disciplinary Committee of
the National Executive Committee were
all pushed and were all moved forward
and it was time after time that the
political leadership should have and
could have absolutely delivered on these
and stopped them and moved on it and
that just did not happen okay and
looking forward who do you want to be
the next leader at the local yeah so we
have I think one of the things that's
really exciting and really interesting
is looking at I am the the runners and
riders who are coming forward we have a
lot of very strong and very good women
coming forward I'm so Caroline was
talking about it Lisa Nandi possibly I'm
too marina because pierced armor you
know there are a great group of people I
they are but what they need to do is
analyze the issues I know actually it's
not about analyzing issues it's about
how do you build that broad coalition
I'm off support going into those
communities will be lost and
understanding why we lost because the
other communities that are going to
suffer under this I own conservative
government okay
Nicole thank you very much for being on
the program this morning and offering
your analysis thank you very much